the man accused of gunning down a
pro-trump supporter in portland
is now dead federal officials say agents
shot and killed him while trying to make
an arrest in washington state
the suspect had said he is quote 100
percent antifa
and defended his actions during an
interview that aired yesterday
what i will say is that i felt that my
life
and other people around me's lives were
in danger
and i felt like i had no choice
but to do what i did
that development coming as portland
nears 100 nights of protests and other
big cities are bracing for the
possibility of
more violence this weekend including in
new york city and certainly others
jesse let's go to you first um this is a
man who is a father of two
and he had been protesting you know all
summer i understand that he felt really
committed to
his cause but he was making a choice and
the choice
ended in his death god rest his soul i
know he leaves behind two children but
my goodness
just do one google search on this guy
it's it's
it's i don't want to speak badly of the
dead but
it's not a pretty picture and to a
certain extent
it's not only wheeler's fault who's a
total failure out there in portland
this guy was picked up on gun charges
just a couple weeks ago
and he they dropped the charges they
didn't even prosecute him he would have
been in jail he wouldn't have been able
to do this
to get on vice while there's a fugitive
task force
looking to arrest you and try to plead
your case shows how
arrogant and emboldened antifa has
become they think they can get away with
that stuff
the video evidence and the eyewitness
testimony
tells a completely different story about
that shooting
from everything we know this was not an
act of self-defense he wasn't saving
anyone's life
this looks like cold-blooded murder he
would have gone away
for life if he hadn't been shot by
deputies
and he was shot because he pulled out a
rifle as they approached him
we warned this was going to happen what
did we say about chop or chaz
you let this thing go someone's gonna
die and they died we've been saying for
a hundred days in portland
someone's gonna die and now they're dead
and it's funny the way the media
characterizes this the media speaks
nicely about the shooter and kind of
denigrates the guy that was shot dead
they're calling this guy
labeling the dead guy like some
right-wing
trump-supporting militia patriot member
and then they whitewash this guy who's
about as radical as they come
it's sad they're lying to you and i
think it's really going to backfire
greg what about the fact that a lot of
these gun crimes
basically don't get prosecuted they let
them go
and then it exacerbates the problem
yeah it's not just this guy you know he
was busted and let go
this happens a lot in other cities with
handguns especially
if they can't control the handguns in
inner cities
how are they going to get have a
national gun control plan is what i
don't understand
i applaud the feds for making the world
safer by eliminating an
armed murderous hooligan i uh the
variables involved in his life whether
he was a family man or
involved in a cause i don't care
i really don't care i think the lesson
every group
needs to learn is that you don't have to
glorify a martyr
because of their skin color you i am not
going to call in sick over this guy
because he's white
all right he murdered a citizen and
jesse's right
i've already seen certain kinds of
language that are
that are being employed to kind of paint
portray him
as a uh as a martyr because he believed
in a cause
um i'm sorry uh you know this started
when the media deliberately mislabeled
violence's protest justified the actions
of misgrants
we knew the violence was happening we
were told by people in the media that we
were crazy
even as the killings spiked we have i
think we have now a 50
increase in murder in new york which we
mentioned yesterday
and we are told that we are just
sensationalizing this
if people listen to us there would be
two men alive right now
that guy and the trump supporter
geraldo what are your thoughts well i
i don't uh i don't miss him i think
jesse's way too
compassionate this was a confessed
killer you live by the gun
you die by the gun you pull a gun on a
federal
fugitive task force and you expect to
survive
i mean that's uh that shows you know
they are so
uh living in their own bubble uh you you
didn't want to blame
mayor wheeler but they've allowed for a
hundred days this anarchy
this disorder this disruption this
violence this
mugging this usurping of private
property
trashing everything you know defying the
rule of law
killing someone in cold blood at
point-blank range
this is where you end up this this
should have happened
50 days ago or a hundred days ago this
was
uh you know this
this antifa thug is exactly what the
president is complaining about these
people
flying between cities bringing their uh
you know their violence with them
conspiring with others to disrupt taking
uh naive innocent
protesters and bending them to their
diabolical purpose this
this guy was a terrorist and he died a
terrorist death
dagon let's get a final thought from you
the feds are on the case
governor kate brown still refusing to
call in the national guard and to
portland
the d.a mike schmidt of multnomah county
not prosecuting many of those people
arrested
but attorney general bill barr said
earlier this week
that they he talked about radicals
crossing state lines and carrying out
planned coordinated attacks on law
enforcement public property and on
private property
guess what that means and andy mccarthy
wrote about this
that the the justice department is going
to be converting
looking at these federal crimes
converting state crimes
into federal crimes crossing state lines
coupled with kind of a loose criminal
organization
that's a racketeering enterprise so
you're talking about
the feds being in charge now we're
talking about
long sentences for these crimes to
prevent
murder potentially so sanctuary
city no more